avec philippe douste-blazy professeur de
médecine ancien ministre de la santé
bonsoir philippe douste-blazy merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
quel est votre état d'esprit en ce
premier jour de déconfinement alors que
jean castex nous prévient ans déjà un
quart en confinement en urgence serait
anticipée le cas échéant qu'est ce qu'on
doit lire entre ses lignes bordeaux lire
d'abord qu'il faut rester extrêmement
prudent et que je vois avec plaisir ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui dans les
transports en commun des français en
grand prix en gros que il fallait pas
repartir brutalement et surtout le port
du masque doit d'être le plus
généralisée possible parce que on
s'aperçoit que c'est tout le monde porte
un masque en particulier d'un transport
en commun dans tous les endroits
confinés y compris les commerces c'est
compris tous les endroits clos alors il
ya une diminution de 95% de la
transmission du virus alors dans le même
temps aujourd'hui on apprend que des
nouveaux foyers de commis 19 ont été
détectés dans notre pays en france mais
aussi en allemagne
aourag épicentre de l'épidémie et en
corée du sud qui avait plutôt de bons
résultats est ce que c'est c'est de
nature à nous inquiéter notamment sur la
survenue d'une deuxième vague
tout à fait je crois que ça veut dire
que ce n'est pas gagné encore qu'il faut
faire attention à tous les
rassemblements ou en corée du sud
c'était dans une boîte de nuit
ailleurs c'était des rassemblements
aussi toujours donc l'important c'est
que nous savons aujourd'hui qu'il y a à
peu près 2003 me contaminer par jour en
france il faut savoir qui est donc il y
à ces fameuses brigades
c'est une fameuse équipe mobile il faut
les mettre essentiellement dans les
endroits où le virus circule le plus
c'est-à-dire la seine saint denis
legrand des ce2 18e ou 19e
arrondissement de paris et surtout que
les médecins généralistes soient le plus
devant possible cec les soignants en pis
la plupart des français en confiance et
donc il faut que ces tests
soit prêt le gouvernement nous dit
qu'ils sont prêts il faut maintenant
aller parler en toute confiance aux
personnes qui sont les plus les plus
savants henry ce qu'on va dire on a bien
vu à singapour c'est d'aider les
migrants on les a vus en allemagne aussi
c'étaient des gens les plus défavorisés
est le cas également philippe
douste-blazy en france des quartiers
défavorisés notamment
oui je suis persuadé que aujourd'hui il
faut ne regarder trois sortes
d'individus
premièrement les personnes âgées donc à
népal il faut vraiment que les ehpad
soin d'éviter que les soignants les
employés qui travaillent dans les ehpad
soit dépistée lui largement possible la
deuxième ce sont les soignants en
général parce que les soignants en
général on sait aujourd'hui que quand
c'est pas justement exactement le poids
de l'hôpital des soignants dans ces demi
le premier nouveau contaminant par jour
et enfin ce sont les personnes je
déballais plus seuls ceux qui sans
domicile fixe ceux qui sont des foyers
de travailleurs où ils sont 20 dans
quarante mètres carrés c'est cela qu'il
faut aller voir
mais cela il faut leur parler je dirais
avec beaucoup de déférence beaucoup de
respect ce sont les médecins
essentiellement les infirmières qui
peuvent faire ce travail est
certainement pas une administration
froide qui donnerait l'impression de
vouloir un peu tracer les amis la
famille et proches vous parlez de cette
crème de la deuxième vague
voulez-vous faire cher philippe
douste-blazy sur ces images que je vais
vous décrire si vous les voyez pas je ne
sais pas si vous avez un poste de télé à
côté de vous canal saint martin qui a
été pris d'assaut en parler parisien
aujourd'hui en ce premier jour de
déconfinement obligeant même la police à
intervenir pour évacuer les quais ça
vous inspire quoi re de de la quiétude
de la colère alors oui d'abord de
l'équipe
deuxièmement c'est ce qui m'a le plus
les a impressionnés c'est que d'abord
premièrement sont des jeunes des jeux de
mots de 25 ans en général
ensuite lorsque la police arrive berry
se lève c'est gentiment comme si il
n'était pas conscient au four du danger
je crois pas le seuil de la mauvaise
volonté je pense que c'est de
l'inconscience et nous savons très bien
que avant 25 ans en tout cas on n'a pas
toujours la conscience notre propre mort
notre propre même mobilité et je crois
que c'est plus de les consciences comme
peugeot donc je crois que c'est très
bien ce travail mais en plus d'aider des
policiers j'aimerais voir peut-être des
secouristes des gens de la croix rouge
des gens des ong pour qu'il n'y ait pas
peut-être que kid qui ne vois pas ça
comme dépressif mais plutôt comme
quelque chose qui leur permet de ne pas
être malade et de ne pas entraîner voir
la maladie ou la mort aujourd'hui le
médecin vous êtes viré justement vers
plus de de confiance de responsabilité
de la part du citoyen français ou au
contraire il faut continuer à réprimer à
sanctionner
comment trouver les curseurs entre les
deux non je crois qu'il faut d'abord
faire comprendre à la population
la distanciation sociale l'envoyé des
jeunes mais je crois qu'en général moi
j'ai vu aujourd'hui je peux promener
aujourd'hui je bois quand même que les
gens ont quand même en tête
distanciation social par contre j'ai vu
qu'il y avait des gens souvent dans les
magasins qui ne portait pas de masque et
ça j'ai envie de dire c'est dommage
parce que toutes les populations
tous les pays qui ont la mortalité la
plus backs même ceux qui se sont permis
de ne pas confiné c'est essentiellement
parce qu'ils avaient le port du masque
essentiellement dans l'europe de l'est
de l'autriche à la hongrie en passant
par chekib la slovaquie on voit que le
port du masque a permis de baisser le le
risque de propagation du virus dans we
dispensation oui on se lave les mains
oui
et l'hydraulique et les alcooliques mais
aussi le port du masque
s'il vous plaît alors les pays qui ont
aussi réussi je parle sous votre
contrôle ce sont des pays qui ont
beaucoup testé en amont qui ont ensuite
tracé isolé ce soir le conseil
constitutionnel a rendu un avis a validé
la loi trop rogations d'état d'urgence
mais 100 sur 100 sur les éléments liés
au traçage et à l'isolément
est ce qu'il faut le déplorer alors moi
sur le traçage je pense qu'ils ont des
éléments que je n'ai pas peut-être sur
les données de santé personnel ça je
pense que il faut être totalement voyez
sur ces dégâts dont on parle et on met
les médecins généralistes en premier
mais bien évidemment le médecin
généraliste ne donnera jamais il faudra
qu'ils donnent jamais le secret médical
à personne en tout cas pas à quelqu'un
qui n'est pas médecin donc je crois
qu'il faut faire attention
ce passage qui est fait par l'assurance
maladie attention il s'est fait par un
médecin oui si c'était par
l'administration
on peut comprendre que le concept
rédactionnel puisse bloquer partons sur
l'isolément je suis formel c'est à dire
que la déco ammann est positif
la seule solution depuis que des
maladies infectieuses existe depuis la
nuit des temps
la seule solution c'est de lui demander
le temps de l'incubation et le temps de
la fin aussi de cette maladie de
s'isoler alors évident si c'est le jeune
père d'un enfant de trois ans il est
seul à la maison avec lui il va pas
partir laisser l'enfant de trois ans et
donc il va se mettre le plus isolé dans
la maison mais non si c'est le ils sont
six il ya la maman et les enfants je
vois qu'il vaut mieux qui s'isole dans
un hôtel thérapeutique et pour 14 jours
ça me paraît extrêmement important c'est
comme ça que les allemands que les
suédois que les norvégiens que les
danois que les canadiens
on fait comme les hong kong et les
singapour taïwan ont cassé la maladie
ont cassé la contamination
merci beaucoup philippe douste-blazy
médecin ancien ministre de la santé
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france ce soir